(El pasado 15 de febrero, el presidente de
los Estados Unidos, Donald Trump decretó
el Estado de Emergencia Nacional.
Lo ha hecho contra la recomendación de sus
propios abogados, con la oposición de buena
parte de los cargos políticos republicanos
y la práctica totalidad de los demócratas
Según el propio presidente, ha tomado esta
decisión para lograr llevar a cabo lo que
el Congreso le impedía: construir el polémico
muro en la frontera con México. Según el
presidente, los Estados Unidos están sufriendo
una auténtica invasión de drogas, inmigrantes
y criminales que ponen en riesgo la mismísima
seguridad nacional.
Ahora, gracias a esta medida, según, Mick
Mulvaney, jefe de gabinete del presidente,
la administración contará con cerca de 8.000
millones de dólares para cerrar a cal y canto
la frontera con México)
[Un momento, amigos, porque esto es importante.
Cuando pusimos en marcha este proyecto, VisualPolitik
nos propusimos crear un canal donde poder
contaros las cosas que ocurrían en el mundo
de una forma libre e independiente. Teniendo
siempre los datos y la información disponibles
como referencia. Y, amigos eso es precisamente
lo que tratamos de hacer cada día.
Te guste o no te guste Donald Trump, o seas
mas o meno partidario de la inmigración,
lo que os vamos a contar en este vídeo es
lo que nos dice la última información disponible.]
Hace poco más de dos años que Donald Trump
llegó a la Casa Blanca con una promesa que
destacaba por encima del resto: construir
un enorme muro a lo largo de toda la frontera
con México.
Un muro de casi 2.000 millas, más de 3.000km
de longitud. Para que os hagáis una idea
de lo que esto significa podemos echar un
vistazo a lo que este proyecto puede terminar
costando. Fijaos.
(Teniendo en cuenta que hay algo más de 600
millas - casi 1.000 km de muros y vallas ya
construidas, terminarlo en su totalidad, tal
y como se propone Trump, es decir, con al
menos 30 pies - 9 metros de altura -y barreras
que dificulten la construcción de túneles,
costaría, según las mejores estimaciones,
más de 30.000 millones de dólares.
El propio Departamento de Seguridad nacional
ha cifrado en más de 20.000 millones el coste
de completar el cierre de la frontera si
se opta por algo más modesto y se alterna,
según los tramos, el muro con vallas. ¡20
mil millones de dólares!)
Y, ojo, hablamos tan sólo del coste de construcción,
porque ya os adelanto que el mantenimiento
de una infraestructura de este tipo no es
algo precisamente barato.
Ahora bien, antes de que emitáis vuestro
veredicto hay unas cuantas preguntas que creo
debemos responder:
¿Por qué este muro ha sido tan polémico?
¿Por qué oponerse a un muro que, digamos,
en principio tiene como fin ordenar la frontera,
hacer que se cumpla la ley y disuadir a muchas
personas a embarcarse en un viaje que les
puede costar la vida?¿Acaso Trump no tiene
razón al decir que con este muro Estados
Unidos sería un país más seguro?
Atentos.
(EL MURO: HISTORIA Y CONSECUENCIAS INESPERADAS)
No, la propuesta de Donald Trump no es exactamente
algo nuevo.
Toda esta historia de cerrar la frontera con
México comenzó ya en 1986, cuando Ronald
Reagan construyó en San Diego 22 kilómetros
de valla de acero. Eso sí, a cambio de legalizar
a 3 millones de inmigrantes ilegales con el
que ha sido el mayor programa de regularización
de la historia de los Estados Unidos.
(Hispanos honran a Nancy Reagan y agradecen
la Amnistía firmada por su esposo Ronald
en el 86. Univisión) 03/2016
[Sí, digamos que eran otros tiempos en el
Partido Republicano].
El caso es que para el año 2000 la longitud
de la frontera fortificada, con muros o con
vallas, apenas había crecido hasta las 60
millas, unos 100 km, casi todo en zonas urbanas.
(Pero en toda esta historia el año 2006 fue
un punto y aparte.
A cambio de una ley para regularizar a casi
todos los inmigrantes ilegales, una ley que
al final no se aprobó, George Bush aceptó
construir una valla a lo largo de casi 700
millas, de la cuales a día de hoy se han
construido la mayor parte.)
La cuestión es que estas barreras han tenido
consecuencias que creo os van a sorprender.
Veréis, hasta la década de los 90 las personas
más o menos podían circular libremente a
través de la frontera, de tal forma que muchos
trabajadores procedentes fundamentalmente
de México, la cruzaban una y otra vez.
Por ejemplo, la cruzaban para trabajar en
el campo durante el verano y luego regresar
a sus casas durante el invierno.
De esta forma aunque eran muchas más las
personas que cruzaban irregularmente la frontera,
el número de inmigrantes ilegales viviendo
en Estados Unidos se mantenía más o menos
estable, en torno a los 3 millones de personas.
(Sin embargo a medida que aumentaron los kilómetros
de vallas, muros y controles fronterizos,
el coste de cruzar la frontera se disparó.
Tan solo entre el año 1995 y el año 2009
se estima que el coste de cruzar la frontera
para un inmigrante pasó de 500 a más de
3.000 dólares. Es decir, se multiplicó por
más de 6.
Todo este gigantesco incremento en el coste
de cruzar la frontera junto a los mayores
riesgos de que te detuvieran, hizo que las
personas que llegaban a Estados Unidos a trabajar
ya no se fueran.)
Y esto es precisamente una de las cosas que
explican que a pesar de contar con 3 veces
más agentes fronterizos y con más de 600
millas de vallas y muros, el número de inmigrantes
ilegales viviendo en Estados Unidos sea muchísimo
mayor que en las décadas de los 90, 80 y
70. Hay más factores, pero este es importante
[Sí, puede que el muro no sea tan efectivo
como parece. Al fin y al cabo el incentivo
a cruzar la frontera es tan grande, que hasta
ahora los muros no han sido impedimento alguno,
simplemente los mecanismos para cruzarlos
se han vuelto más caros, favoreciendo, incluso,
el efecto contrario al que se pretendía]
(Pero es que además en los últimos años
se ha producido otro gran cambio, hoy la inmensa
mayor parte de los inmigrantes ilegales ya
no cruzan la frontera de forma ilegal, sino
que llegan legalmente.)
[Vamos, que cojen un avión se plantan en
Estados Unidos y cuando expira el tiempo de
permanencia máximo simplemente se quedan.
Y ahí el muro pues no va a hacer nada].
Pero, amigos, todo esto responde tan sólo
parcialmente a las preguntas que nos hemos hecho.
Nos falta ver como el muro puede afectar realmente
a esa invasión de criminales que Donald Trump
considera toda una emergencia nacional.
(LA (NO) EMERGENCIA NACIONAL)
En la Casa Blanca lo tienen muy claro: la
frontera con México se ha convertido en un
coladero de criminales. Cerrarla a cal y canto
es una cuestión de seguridad nacional.
Pero amigos, ¿hasta qué punto pensáis que
esto es cierto?
Pues vamos a ver, si esto es verdad lo normal
es que se produzcan tres cosas:
Primero, lógicamente, que a través de la
frontera lleguen muchos criminales.
Segundo, que la propia frontera sea un lugar
peligroso, por ejemplo para las personas que
trabajan en la guardia fronteriza ¿no?
[Vamos a ver, si la frontera está infestada
de criminales y narcos cruzandola como Pedro
por su casa… este trabajo tiene que ser
realmente peligroso, ¿no os parece?]
Y tercero que los estados más perjudicados
sean precisamente los que más inmigrantes
ilegales tienen.
Pues bien, te hago una pregunta, - sí, sí
a ti - y no vale no responder: ¿crees que
estos tres puntos se cumplen?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(Empecemos por la primera cuestión, si la
frontera es un coladero de criminales, lo
normal es que la atraviesan muchos criminales.
Pues según los datos del propio gobierno
de los Estados Unidos esto no es del todo
así.
Los inmigrantes ilegales detenidos por las
patrullas fronterizas tienen unos historiales
de criminalidad muy reducidos y por cierto,
el dato cada vez es más pequeño.
Tan solo el 0,04% de los inmigrantes ilegales
detenidos tenían condenas por los delitos
más graves de homicidio o asesinato.)
Esto es una tasa menor que la del conjunto
de los Estados Unidos. Aquí lo que llegan
son básicamente familias.
¿Quereis otro dato?
La tasa de asesinatos de miembros de la guardia
fronteriza, es decir de las personas que están
en primera línea contra todos esos criminales
- es de apenas 2 personas por cada 100.000
agentes. 10 veces menos que la tasa de 19,7
que tienen el resto de cuerpos de policía
en el resto del país. Incluso es menos de
la mitad que la tasa general en los Estados Unidos.
Vamos, que los guardias fronterizos están
más seguros que el resto de ciudadanos de
los Estados Unidos.
En otras palabras, si en la frontera hay una
emergencia nacional, entonces en las ciudades
de Estados Unidos… no se, se tiene que estar
viviendo toda una guerra campal.
Pero ya lo que alguno está pensado… Enrique
esto es porque los criminales son muy listos
y la patrulla fronteriza no los detiene.
Bueno, pues en ese caso veamos qué ocurre
con las tasas de delincuencia y criminalidad
en los territorios aledaños a la frontera,
que serán en los primeros donde actúan todos
estos criminales, ¿no?
Pues amigos, la tasa de criminalidad en los
23 condados que hay a lo largo de la frontera
con México está por debajo de la del resto
de condados que no están en la frontera con
México.
En Texas, la tasa de condenas criminales de
inmigrantes ilegales es casi la mitad, la
mitad, que la que se da entre la población
nativa.
Y por último amigos el tercer punto, ¿Será
cierto que los estados más peligrosos de
Estados Unidos son los que más inmigrantes
ilegales tienen porque estos son más propensos
a cometer crímenes?
Pues no, tampoco. De hecho todo lo contrario.
(Como los inmigrantes ilegales son menos propensos
a cometer crímenes que la población nativa,
- Y los inmigrantes legales lo son aún menos,
por cierto - ocurre que en los estados cuanto
más porcentaje de la población está formada
por inmigrantes ilegales más seguros son.)
Amigos, podemos discutir si la inmigración
tiene efectos positivos o negativos sobre
la economía - que es algo de lo que ya hemos
hablado aquí en VisualPolitik - pero en Estados
Unidos no tiene un efecto negativo sobre
la criminalidad, todo lo contrario. De la
misma forma que el muro tampoco va a frenar
la inmigración ilegal.
[Con lo que tirar decenas y decenas de miles
de millones en algo que no sirve para nada,
pues no parece lo más inteligente]
Por eso muchas personas se oponen al dicho
muro, incluido mucho, muchísimos republicanos.
Con los datos en la mano, la política del
muro es una política chapucera.
Por no hablar del abuso de poder que supone
que el ejecutivo de Trump esté tratando de
saltarse el poder del Congreso y la separación
de poderes con una figura pensada para casos
de emergencia nacional.
Y esto evidentemente no es una emergencia,
entre otras porque ni la seguridad nacional
está en riesgo ni es algo que se vaya a solucionar
de forma inmediata.
En fin amigos, con este vídeo hemos querido
recoger los principales datos y ponerlos sobre
la mesa para que sepamos porqué tantas y
tantas personas se oponen al muro. Y ojo,
oponerse al muro, no implica necesariamente
estar a favor de las fronteras abiertas, sino
simplemente en contra de una idea que con
los datos en la mano solo parece buena para
las empresas que construyan el muro.
[Por cierto, para construirlo el gobierno
de los Estados Unidos tiene que expropiar
los derechos sobre una enorme cantidad de
territorio, lo que tampoco va mucho con la
cultura norteamericano, ¿no?].
Por cierto, una última noticia: los próximos
días 8 y 9 de marzo estaremos en León participando
en unas jornadas en la Universidad. Te dejamos
más información en la descripción, por
si te animas a acompañarnos.
Y ya sabes si te ha gustado el vídeo dale
a like y nos vemos pronto.